I am here now.
Because of you.
You created me.
And for that
I bless you.
Move! Move!
Move!
And tell me story.
Tell me.
Every detail.
I woke up.
from where?
From a nightmare.
What was it about?
Then?
Then, me and lots took care of their business.
Hold up! Hold up! Back up!
Do you left something out?
Are you writing a book?
They all lived hapilly ever after.
No, they didn't know that.
Because for the first time there is something you don't know.
Something nobody told you.
You wanted the prophecy!
This is your prophecy.
I don't come with manual.
I know your story.
Behold!
The man who pulled sword from stone.
I'm not getting drown into this mess.
There's an army of you.
There's only one of me.
I'll talk.
Happy to talk.
But there is no way
that i'm fighting.
So what happens now?
You know what happens now.
You're quickly becoming a legend.